a mídia monteiro que é que estás a fazer
melhor não tenho o miguel monteiro que
já foi miguel monteiro e chocaram eo ala
pivô antawn jamison monteiro gritos e
que o preto sexo é uma nova conta pra
não ser banido pela manteiga ó eu não
tenho por que me manter explica porquê
porque agora estou super contente com a
nova casa de ópera la em breve chegue
hoje embora vai tão bonito porque é uma
maneira de dar um soco na orelha da bola
para 00 ainda não começou o jogo miguel
monteiro ainda não começou o jogo a mil
títulos por ele ser um problema é vã o
américa deixou o hotel e miguel matou um
outro furto
então eu não acho isso um ted monteiro
ce evolução do chão miguel isso não vai
ficar assim não vai rolar
o que eles não temem não terminou logo
deus agora é uma tatoo milhão
agora sim já teve tanto vingança e
miguel monteiro não te deixa tudo em
campo agora vingança do que gasta depois
mais dinheiro mas no futuro miguel no
futuro mais velho não tem expressa não
tem um expresso miguel por robertinho
vai ter eu vou segurá lo agora eu vou
jogar fora é só imaginar a óleo chegar
lá mas que jogo incrível
olha só usa ai ai ai meu deus culpa
minha
com isso miguel monteiro
a gente olha aqui gente me chamou e eu
não tenho não faz hoje pelo jornal nem
monteiro ainda modificar minha memória
universal
eu não quero mais sofrer para sofrer
encaminha manter o que posso fazer é
ficar amiga manteve em casa jogando em
sala de jogos sala miguel de ver miguel
monteiro está cheira muito mal miguel no
hawai minha luta é retomar o ano a
miguel artista chora milhão
tude gestão no relógio para o texto meu
hobby miguel ir embora e agora miguel
toda a montanha mais fruta possui 103
cabeça do cachorro na zona montanhosa
que fazia miguel miguel monteiro neto
estágio sem o deputado e eu não tenho o
que não está na tua cama não está 100
porque ela estava e também réu porque
também a saída seria muito legal o juro
já parei de gravar a abrir portas rápido
do que fui duto muito ruim sério
[Aplausos]
deus é a culpa mas seria vingança miguel
monteiro
olha só de ver suas formas diferentes
formas das raízes do nosso país e de
lula ajudou os pais é menor queda de
pesca pessoal os novos raios x que
magnifica escutaram os novos jogos
disputados
olha esse foi um sinal de união não tem
não vai lá buscar a deus nada agora
ainda vou consultar a minha é só ir à
oficina
eu só aí a água tomou água tão boa
quanto a minha anterior em uma briga de
cada amiga não ter desculpa feita que
miguel vamos conversar ainda pode soar
como um fado e miguel ainda pode uma
cola ou não isso não
isso não as chances não legal a fonte
não iam francis não não desculpa não se
inscreva no canal do miguel monteiro eo
espaço subscrevam só eu posso achar um
milhão eu peço perdão miguel monteiro
tomou uma flor do meu filho miguel
matéria profissional ainda um tanto na
esquerda como já que a situação não usar
mídias no total 11 eu tomava podem agora
que quer inteiro vai gente não teve em
carmel
é ser burro galo ter o meu
o preto eo branco adriane e não consiga
nada que sugira são miguel monteiro
miguel monteiro não perca talentos uma
senhora se comigo não tem como tomar
banho de farinha onde aconteceu o
impensável
por isso tocar fogo está pegando fogo
até aí quem vai limpar isso miguel